[Background voices]
>> Hello, YouTube. Ah-this is Achim Steiner.
I head the environment program of the United
Nations that has its home in Nairobi, Kenya.
I wanted to respond to this question because
much of what you may be hearing and reading
in the headlines of newspapers and TV reports
about Davos this year is about economic slowdown,
recession, the worries of the financial markets,
subprime rates; and some have been wondering
what happened to the discussion about the
state of the planet and issues such as climate
change, global warming, our earth's _____.
I think for 2008 there are great opportunities
to show that as we respond to the challenge
of global warming we can do so also in the
context of perhaps some of the economic indicators
now pointing towards a slowdown.
Responding to climate change is about doing
things more efficiently-about investing in
your markets. It's about creating new jobs.
It's about bringing new technologies in. And
I think we need to speak to our leaders-the
political leaders, the economic leaders-this
year to make sure that we don't fall back
under the old trap of arguing that doing something
about climate change is a luxury and if the
times economically become harder we can't
afford to do it. I think the opposite is true
and it will depend on a lot of you speaking
to your senators, congressmen and appease
local leaders and mayors because they can
do a lot this year, and in particular with
a view to reaching a new agreement on climate
change which is what we now have to worry
about for the future. Bye-bye.